[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
seuls dans le monde 4 heures du matin
dans les flashs de 107 chambres d'hôtes
je m'appelle m décroche pas contre mais
révélée d'eau au milieu de la piste de
danse dernier verre et je pense à toi
chaude je pense un toit du chemin
sainte-foy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens et
c'est à pau contre mal est à vous
[Musique]
mouallem
qu'est ce qu'on sait mais c'est oublier
une nuit de plus
solitude dans le toubib okumus non mais
tu décroches pas une chaude je pense à
toi de chaudes je pense à toi trop
chaude je pense
[Musique]
non
jours
c'est ta pauvre martin
est ce concert est conçu
[Musique]
quand je t'en ai couru dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
je
[Musique]
obama
paul est un roman
laisse moi
leers impôts qu'entre main
c'est un pauvre mam
c'est un faucon femmes
[Musique]
temps
entre main
jusqu'au semestre sous les
[Applaudissements]